what was that last day on set like oh
I'm gonna start crying now even like
thinking about it
that's constants whoo holding back tears
talking about the final season of fresh
off the boat at ABC's TCA press day yeah
I was really sad like I just really love
the the cast and crew so much and it was
just is just really sad to say goodbye
constants also reflected on what she
will miss the most about the show I'm
gonna miss the crew a lot I really loved
them and with Randall he's just so funny
but he's also like just like one of the
nicest people to ever work with Chelsea
it's just has become such a wonderful
friend and just such like a supportive
person in my life and then um and the
boys are just like awesome I'm so proud
of like you know the young men that
they've become and like you know
Hollywood could mess people up
especially kids and the fact that they
still like it hasn't done that to them
like they really have good heads on
their shoulders they're kind people
they're compassionate they're excited
they're passionate they're driven they
are their own people you know it's it's
been so cool to watch and I'm really
proud of fresh-off-the-boat is the first
primetime stay calm
featuring an Asian family in nearly
three decades
so when acts would mark she hopes the
series will leave on the world constant
old eats he she hopes representation
becomes the norm well I was just saying
like you know when we first started it
was such a historic thing and my hope is
that one day people look back and
they're like oh that was historic to us
today it's just normal and that would be
like the dream and I think that's
happening slowly yeah I think progress
is definitely happening
[Music]